in these last few days when CNN and
MSNBC and all these other places when
they could have been reporting on what
was happening honestly when they could
have been telling their people for years
what was really going on here and stop
making it seem like Republicans are all
racist and Democrats are all
automatically good guys but they didn't
do that but now they're seeing the polls
they're seeing the trends and it is too
hard to ignore so what's happening on
CNN well even Democrat activists are
showing up on CNN and saying man this is
this is absolutely on us this is Hillary
Rosen who has been a Democrat strategist
for a couple decades I think she worked
for Hillary Clinton if I'm not mistaken
she's a Democrat strategist and just
listen to The Way She lays it out to
this panel Hillary you have a different
take maybe than bakari on Democrats yeah
I'm
I'm a loyal Democrat but I am not happy
I just think that we are you know we did
not listen to voters in this election
and I think we're gonna have a bad night
and you know this conversation is not
going to have much impact on Tuesday but
I hope it has an impact going forward
because when voters tell you over and
over and over again that they care
mostly about the economy
listen to them all right so it's not
easy for a Democrat strategist to get up
on CNN and say we really screwed the
pooch on this thing now I don't know
what makes someone like Hillary and I've
interviewed her before I think many many
years ago I don't know what would make
someone like her at this point in 2022
say I'm a loyal Democrat like I just
don't know what's left there that's sort
of like the Bill Maher thing but okay
putting that aside she's acknowledging
hey people actually just cared about the
economy and crime those are pretty much
the big two right now and Democrats
instead of focusing on that well
actually they kind of focused on it and
made both those things worse right
defund the police inflation reduction
act blah blah blah they were also
focused on chopping kids genitals off
they were also focused on neo-racism
they were also focused on destroying our
history and tearing down statues and
everything else so the Democrats know
they're in for an ass a whoopin